heck having just insulted 50 states
including our own and now Canada now not
everyone seen the gravity falls v-log so
now they're gonna have to go and see
every single state that we consulted
including the 51st being Canada oh I
don't think we're able to get to every
state but I think we've got about 30 we
got a good half of them at least um but
anyway uh this is our real thought of
having it be October yes oh I wait all
year
I just fucking wait all year for fall to
come and it really took its time we
didn't have a fall in September it was
really weird I do find it funny though
that we finally had fall weather pretty
much September 29th September 30th is
when it started
yeah it's oh no it's earlier yeah we've
only had like a couple days going into
October first and now it's like 60
degrees and I just want to hold onto it
forever it just feels so good okay um so
we're gonna talk about I mean I think we
can kind of do just general like the
Ernest movies we saw real bitches aren't
quick some ups and but mainly Ernest
scared stupid because you know we're
doing Halloween and stuff like that and
I can we just go down the line real fast
when you start with the first movie uh
Ernest goes to camp
I thought kind of sucked it's like the
first movie and it's like it's the
classic man you know you know what it
feels like it feels like a movie that
was already five movies down and it's
like it's Ernest yeah but I thrown some
kids throwing so that would be a good
time well yeah but no that's what it
feels like it feels like they start off
with that movie because so much of it is
on these kids and the kids are annoying
and stupid and they throw in this dumb
last minute like forest warrior shit at
the end where it's like Oh Ernest is
like the chosen one that he has the
spirit of the not getting hit with a gun
some it's a very really bad very 80s
movie um that would have been the Adam
Sandler film um it's time the plot is
like the same sort of like God made the
can but I will say this it gave us one
thing that I totally forgot about I
think most people do but somebody you
showed it to me and how do you forget
about there's this song called gee I'm
glad it's raining do you remember that
song no it is a surprisingly sad
depressing emotional song and I like
uh why do you leave earnest concret it's
kind of like that it's really fucking
weird I was like wow there's like this
one really genuinely sad moment it's
kinda like the blue bird song and uh
follow that bird
you just watch it like what the fuck
we're fighting right now no we're we're
like a thousand kindergarteners like
we're ready to slit their wrists ya know
it's kind of life and I don't know how I
forgot about how most people did maybe
it's just in between so much other
nonsense but yeah so it's don't like the
first no very much uh they got Ernest
saves Christmas which is really stupid
but by I didn't ask me when I thought of
the first Phil I just assumed do you
agree yeah I me like I'd say I thought
it was okay are you fellas okay out of
all of the we're talking about the
Nerdist movies okay so you gotta like
set the bar pretty had a great poster
poster was wonderful it really did stick
out in the old video rental places
particularly we got like the big box cap
yeah um as far as the bar is set for
Ernest movies it was alright it is not
money even by Aaron is movie space I
thought was pretty low it is not my
favorite the the undisputed indisputable
king of all Ernest movies is still
Ernest saves Christmas yes which is just
great there's no even arguing I mean if
you try to claim on the elements wrong
you're actually factually wrong there is
no subjectivity here
you're objectively my sister um science
is proven that Ernest saves Christmas he
keeps the Christ in Christmas yeah oh
this does keep the Christ in Christ
yeah they I know because a lot of bumper
sticker and nowhere else in the movie oh
my god all buddy ass from Ernest back in
Christmas yeah nicely done
um but yeah it's a yeah it's not good
but it's but god bless that I love it
it's so stupid and so corny but do you
put this it hearts in the right place
really is really it's one of those where
like it totally slides on a few funny
moments you know a few bizarre feeling
almonds and just this absolute heart and
so much of it comes from what I declared
the greatest Santa Clause has ever hit
film absolutely yeah I'm also the Sultan
from Aladdin yeah uh he's just got such
an adorable voice when he looks
that's what's so funny when I watch
Aladdin like and when I I see I'm just
like they didn't change his kid they
made him a little tubby er but they all
made summer no but the animation artist
it's like the exact same face oh yeah
like it's creepy how they just captured
the dude's face um but yeah so it's it's
an innocent little dumb film it is dumb
but it is just we probably like it's
heart was in the right place it's got
the best Santa Claus I've seen in any
movie I fucking believe that dude is
yeah Claus um and we're probably riding
mostly on the stealth oh yeah no no no I
God like I'll still admit it's stupid
it's dumb we're riding a 90 percent
nostalgia 10% that this is still
probably the best of this series yeah so
my concern is me yeah yeah they tried
this is the best you're gonna get so
that plus nostalgia I actually
legitimately enjoy watching this movie
around Tom's then you have Ernest goes
to jail which again is stupid but he's
so bizarre that it actually works I kind
of it's my second-favorite joy watching
it it's so stupid it makes no sense but
it's so bizarre in how it doesn't make
any sense and so strange and how
colorful it is and how visual is in the
jokes and it's just give jim Varney a
chance to lie if you thought he was
already hamming it up his all involve
all evil Ernest is a work of art like I
didn't realize like cuz he came back as
I was at slinky the dog and territory
when he died I suddenly realize it was
like I do kind of miss him I was yes
like it I know really nice to disco me
Burt thought he was the anti-crime did
you know
you know then Jim Carrey came along and
probably took some of the Ornish yeah um
yeah I got a strange attachment to the
Ernest movies at least the early ones
and yeah there was just some about jim
Varney was like you know what it it's so
bizarre and go for broke it's almost
endearing ya know and everybody here's
the thing that we didn't know cuz we
were kids growing up I mean fuckin every
adult hated Ernest I mean they're just
like oh my god this is still they took
that idiot from those commercials and
they just gave him movies that's so not
fair there's so many bear movies that we
can make and stuff and you're right
there are much better movies you can
make but well does this happen later
erases the same thing about Jim Carrey I
mean we've got Adam Sandler and Rob
Schneider the new whipping boys um now
we've moved on to directors we got
Michael Bay and at night now I haven't
seen the visit yet I'm find it I'm
trying to think who the equivalent of
Ernest would be now uh this is my carrot
uh-uh no carrot tops along go on I was
almost gonna say Anne Hathaway but that
seems really unfair there's something
calling the Anne Hathaway syndrome where
just everybody hates you for no reason
that's going around I always sort of
felt that like yeah why does everybody
hate this person like gee I never begin
yes like she acts fine she seems nice I
don't get it uh but we're getting
sidetracked I don't know who the new
Ernest is now but yeah I'm trying
something that would have come out of
something small like the commercials and
I was it I guess we did it that in some
respect with like the the cavemen who
got the sick guy you know I do you like
it just like flow the progressive woman
whatever like if you gave her movies
it's like she's not the worst thing in
the world I don't you think she's really
that bad I laugh at one or two of the
commercials but if like if suddenly
she's this big star and they're giving
her movies since the popin
what the hell it is is so fucking stupid
stuff even though she's probably fine
pair of I know pictures presents
flow hello oh my aunt's in town okay hey
I you know I have to go there um but uh
yeah so you got this movie this Ernest
goes to jail again it was a hit at both
all three of these movies were a
surprise hits and I was they are nice
people
but Ernest goes to jail was the most
slapstick II and I think the best at the
slapstick yeah I mean it really was not
there was a no sense but it's like by
God they're just throwing all these
weird it was very much like a three just
giant Three Stooges routine and on that
level I thought that one did it the best
is like okay this is literally just like
jokes for little kids
yeah and just everything is over the
slapstick everyth the slapstick comedy
was passable like um I guess just so big
and weird you kind of just gotta go I
don't usually see this in movies like
even kids movie so I mean just kind of
uh you take it oh and then came Ernest
goes to Afghanistan hey God I took a
darker turn oh my god
Ernest signee Ernest signing up to fight
the Russians um a young rose and kissy
Ernest is like a chair it's a young
working with a young Osama bin Laden it
was a it was like a bosom buddies kind
of like a comedy road picture it it was
Ernest goes to Isis it was not it was
not a hit no no well we had Ernest
scared stupid was the next one it even
as kids we knew this was bad yeah we
just walked out and we were so ready to
like this movie cuz we really like okay
let's be honest I feel like I was maybe
12 or 13 when this film came out and I
was already at that tipping point where
I'm like I don't think this is for me
anymore
like see and I was ready for an earthly
especially in our example years he would
have been like maybe 10 yeah I was ready
and then I think after I saw it that's
why I said you know I don't think I can
do this anymore
oh it just I know it's it's weird to say
the Ernest movie wasn't funny cuz a lot
but Jesse you're like Ernest is funny
but as is kind of sued is not a serious
evil work yeah we know his why don't you
say it seriously um we uh you go uh no
this movie I just had a moment of
sobriety I'm like what the fuck am I
saying you know what it is it felt like
they said he made me want to do again
let's do like what made Ernest goes to
camp not
can let's make that the whole movie oh
yeah that's a good way and you know it's
somebody who didn't mind their earnest
ghost
okay so there's like so there's a scene
and there's a lot of these in the Ernest
movies where it's like Ernest needs to
escape jail it's like the whole thing so
somehow he gets it disguised as this old
middle-aged woman character trying to
escape it makes no sense the best life
is disguised oh no no it is probably his
best character um but he tries to escape
and they throw him back in now that
makes no sense but it connects to the
story he's trying to escape
here these characters pop out we don't
know where they're coming from how he
has these guys rooms or anything like
that and they just talked to the camera
you're not even sure who he's talking to
and it doesn't connect with anything I
mean fucking anything is like hey this
guy can do some characters let's just
give him some characters for a bit and
it just connects to nothing and it's
like I feel like that's like half the
movie I same three little characters I
one of my big problems is yeah as I said
it wasn't funny um I just remember like
when I first saw it like this dingy
cinema in the Laureus suburbs or
something like when we were kids I just
remember being really really bored and
that to me is the worst thing a movie
can do for me is bore me like if I was a
kid in the movie bored to me something
you failed cuz something's wrong because
I'm a kid I should be easy to entertain
yeah and like a lot of films I know I'm
just like okay that was stupid I
realized I was stupid I liked it as a
kid it was like they didn't bore me
though like if you bore me as a kid like
that's a special kind of dumb what in
the interest homage in so much of it was
just I just remember long boring scenes
not laughing it was one of the early
movies where I almost remember falling
asleep cuz we saw like a late showing of
it yeah and it was like I think in the
middle of the school week and like we
had to get up and like the crack of dawn
always through school and I was one of
those where I'm just like wow I may be
actually too tired for this
what do you remember when we saw this
film I mean we saw it once and then like
maybe we saw bits of it on TV or some by
scene is filming gears and then when we
did for the South Shore critic like I'm
watching all these scenes I'm just turn
to you I'm like do you even
member theses and I only use about me
now
cannibal that I'm looking back and I'm
like do you really this you with a
dumpster do you mer the scene with the
opening where they capture the troll or
whatever is chasing the girl and
everything it's like that I bet I
remembered I remember them kind of
putting him just because I remember it I
just remember wondering what the hell it
was the first time I saw what and then
she's my but the Puritans or whatever in
it for an earnest movie it was very
unpleasant he was patrol was not funny
it was not unpleasant to watch look at
resolution it for something
aimed at little kids like little kids it
was legitimately scary yeah oh my kids
crying and remember which is not
something I would have associated with
Ernest and we got raised on 80 shit yes
so we were kind of used to apathy but I
was Kelly you know for a nurse movie
should and I think that's a thing it's
the tone it's like we were used to it in
films that were aimed at like kids a
little higher up on the age scale but
for something that really like you
thought you could take your
three-year-old to it I just remember
there are a lot of kids flipping the
fuck out in the cinema when we saw it
the first time like well it was
something like Return to Oz or secret
name and stuff the scary parts are
warranted they're earned because they
know they have this other stuff that's
going to be there's something worth
fighting for or there's like this good
character is innocence or something to
balance it out and usually Marie
yeah that's the thing you're telling a
story this is just this fucking earnest
yeah my kids you don't want it's not
like we're gonna go really dark real
earnest reserve back
you don't want stories you know what
like and I mean that's the thing it's
like they kind of went for like bigger
scares and dark kind of unpleasantness
in something that you can't even it's
like you took goosebumps way more
seriously there's like so I don't know
oh yeah you know the fight thing too at
the very end all these other sort of
trolls pop up and they're actually
they're kind of goofy-looking and
they're actually kind of not bad designs
I was kind of wishing they were in more
the movie okay so yeah these are weird
looking things like got big eyes and
where they kind of look like you know
like old 80s trading cards like Garbage
Pail Kids or something like that and I
was kind of wishing there's more of them
in the movie and they're just served
there at the end and I'm also thinking
why could the mean
all look like this or why could the main
troll be funny or why could he be
different like I mean he's literally
just this angry little thing quick no
I'm gonna get you boy you're stone up
it's like that's it you can do anything
with this fucking beast and you don't do
anything with it I'm not gonna lie like
again it sounds so weird for an earnest
movie it seemed kind of derivative it
seemed it seemed like a spirited meteor
but just like I felt like Monster Squad
had already covered this yeah I felt
like to remember what was the did the
Disney Channel special mr. Boogedy
Boogedy I remember the fucking I
remember thinking when I saw this movie
that was like this just reminds me that
mr. Boogedy thing that came out a few
years earlier yeah um so everything
about that was done better that was all
built up to the end and Jose it was
stupid but it was legit good build up so
I just it all kind of felt derivative
like I'm not saying Ernest saves
Christmas or Ernest goes to jail was
shockingly original idea but I'm like
all right there just am a goofy fun
doing this this this just felt like it
was assembled from other movies but like
I give I give the other dude like Ernest
goes to camp as definitely comes out of
that 80's camp thing we I go and uh but
the other two at least I felt like and I
just doing their own thing what do you
want argue to do anything else I'm kind
of new to you know SEO was new Ernest
riding the sleigh going around the world
I was kind of knew the look of Ernest
goes to jail we gonna argue needs to
necessarily be new but it didn't feel
like it was pieced together out of other
films yeah this just literally felt like
somebody read a few other Halloween
scripts there's like Luke shoved into
one movie the one thing no there's two
things I got from this film that I'm
kind of like okay well that was kind of
neat without the one the only joke of
the whole movie that made me laugh is
why he says I never know when they'll
quit just ask my third grade teacher and
just I don't know where it cuts to his
third grade teacher and there's Ernest
writing on the wall he never knew when
to quit and he hits she hits him in the
back of my head I like that was so odd
he can't help but laugh it was just so
out of nowhere uh but no the other two
things is Eartha Kitt was so bizarre
fucking mom terrific yeah anything and
it's kind of like okay I'll I'll buy
this cuz it's
can I love with a kid um and then uh
that weird joke that you before the
internet you had to do research in order
to get at all and that's the MEAC joke
which is so straight nobody would know
what the fuck me AK is does it exist is
what is it and the fact I had to do
research on it I kind of respect because
that is just so strong egg so play art
for the people you know what was it was
like Bull Garrett was Bulgarian a
Bulgarian liquid or something like that
that actually doesn't exist but people
always sort of said it might exist or
might not and it's like supposed to be
some sort of delicacy that's kind of
like you know jelly ish or like syrup
eeeh or something I was actually hoping
that if you would explain it to the
audience I would remember what the fuck
you were talking about cuz out no no cuz
he thinks like this is all a ruse just
to be like man I don't remember that all
let's see if I can remember from his
explanation no cuz they figure out its
milk but there's a letter missing so he
thinks it's me act like he goes to yak
before he goes to milk no I kind of
remand it's like it's so bizarre and
that he actually has a jar of it and
you're just thinking like where the hell
did he get this thing that kind of
doesn't exist so it was so strange and
that was part of the humor I kind of
liked in the other earnest movies deal
it's just so strange yeah and yeah and
then it just turned into pretty much a
straight to VHS movie uh so ya know what
don't bother
rent ParaNorman that was a Waco there's
a lotta better yeah a lotta better
movies to see oh and then and again we
say this is kind of Suze and his kind of
food
Ernest Kennedy uh it started the slide I
think of the Ernest films into
mediocrity he actually did watch one or
two of the VHS ones I think I watched
less is there I swear to god there's
like an Ernest goes to Africa there was
a probably shaft goes no no kamae I
haven't seen it but now it's getting
like this reputation of being like
unbelievably racist and now I'm really
curious to see it um but no I saw Ernest
goes back to school I saw that one
uh and it was bad just like I said I I
think we're adjusting it chairs like
yeah I don't think we're gonna do any
more these we we felt betrayed you
betrayed us Ernest
um it was a die though point where it's
like I think we're growing up Oh all
good things must come to an 80s um no
but there was something I will say
watching you no no watching scared
stupid and goes back to school and stuff
like that did make me look and realize
like yeah with saves Christmas and goes
to jail they're stupid but it's like
something did work more in those movies
that did in these other ones um and
there is a fire is like what it is
there's a doubt ooh everything like a
way to everything like a kind of Zen and
within the low bar of our standard of
earnest movies they found a way to make
something work for a while and then they
lost it yeah um but uh yeah it's like
it's a thing with the Care Bears movies
I'm like that the first time but I like
this works within the framework based
setup and then the sequels get
increasingly workers yeah uh except we
did have doc odd um sound of a game of
disappearing bears
um but yeah and uh I tried the only hard
thing I can think about to talk about is
maybe do you remember the show hey Vern
it's Ernest mermaids Ernest yeah the
best bit of the show the best of the
best bits about it were just like when
you busted at Verne's place yeah he does
in the movies like that was that was
really the only really funny thing about
using burned yes he had like it was this
every morning
that was a setting the other Saturday
morning outside a morning the
live-action yeah I mean it wasn't a
cartoon but it ran during those I can't
remember if it was good it probably
wasn't by Camaro's goodbye do remember
it was strange I were man I worked I've
admiring for how strange a one cuz he
was just it was kind of like you can't
do that on television where it was like
just a series of cutaway things and
sketches except it was even more random
and more strange he's we're fucking
weird
yeah well that that might have been like
that maybe I know yeah well there's a
lead over I kind of still considered the
80s to about 90 - yeah um well when
there's a sense of like just throw
we don't fucking care that's usually the
80s the noise the 90s to be honestly
kick in summer of Jurassic Park that to
me is like the real I go a little before
it I know I gotta go like that summer
dress work is really the kickoff of the
nineties agree I'm like that's what the
90s everything that's what everything
went extreme it's like hey we're not
gonna be like but before that be like
when everything's qj-- everything jacket
earrings in your face like that's kind
of a 90 but you know when you look at
fashion trends and you look at the music
and everything you look at 1990 91 92
like I'm sorry go back and look at the
commercials everything you're we're
still transitioning I said 93 is kind of
weird I eighties I'm like look at all
news footage I was like there was some
news story about Hillary Clinton they
ran some clip from fucking 1994 and I'm
like oh my god the shoulders on the show
has no hair and the the color I'm like
it literally look like 1988 so like we
still were transitioning out of that
slowly just like I still kind of
considered the early 2000s kind of part
of the late nineties yeah so I'm
nineties feel um but yeah so so there
you go that's a server take on her
skirts too but just the earnest movies
in general they got the stupid part
right yes
uh and if you were Todd when they got
the scared part right so though I think
of both the the Christmas and jail are
always gonna have a place in my heart no
matter what even some of those old
commercials can be a little funny the
earnest commercials um not many but some
of them Ken uh and yeah there's just
something about earnest IQ I never quite
got on the hate I completely understand
it but I never really got on to it um
there's just something too naive it
isn't about it I can't quite hate it
it's like no you so much those two films
and there's some Adam Sandler films that
I like ya know there's an but I
understand when people just like God
Christ I hate Adam saying I hate that
I'm like I get it you know there was
some Deen cook routines that I actually
found funny but the oh my god I can't I
get it like it's the same thing with
Ernest is like there are some things
about it I like I get it if you don't ya
um either mm oh I never I never minded
uh Dean cook that much either
like I don't love him I don't get like
the huge obsession then with the sneeze
you know people's a double team what
movie do we do
that he was in I I forgive ya we were he
was tearing he was off on that but as a
stand-up it's like I don't I don't know
he just seems like any other stand-up
but I did hear like his dole lewin CK's
jokes and stuff but by got that
crossover they did on Louie
that was fuckin hilarious and how
seriously they both treated it I mean it
I'm sorry
he can steal some jokes and we can get
more crossovers like that cuz that was
fucking hilarious
um again that I get why he I'm annoying
um I get you know after that movie I
could see it more um I never quite got
the extreme hate uh maybe it was it I
think cuz more fro because he was so
popular and people are like why is this
guy so popular um I think it's the same
thing with Twilight though Twilight did
become so insanely fun stupid um it's
like I think people hate him more
because of how popular it is if you just
saw the first movie on TV or some stupid
whatever you don't think anything of it
but the fact that it's so there are
Euler here are worse yeah it's much
worse it's like fifty Shades of Grey
that movie I'm like wow I really wanted
this to be way worse yeah that would
have been funnier Lisa Bella has turned
into one of my favorite villains ever um
but yeah so there you go that's the
Ernest movies uh we'll probably do more
in this Towser Wien movies I think we
kind of been holding off so that we
could talk about during this month so
there's definitely more on the way and
we will see you there
happy October boo